Hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel. So if you read the title of
this video, you can pretty clearly see
that uh I am going to be making another
systems design series. Uh this one is
just going to be uh for the questions
for interviews and we're just going to
go over those. Now the first thing that
should be in your head is, "Wow, Jordan,
you're a real hypocrite." Uh because
this is now like the third time that
I've said I'm not going to do this again
and uh and proceeding to do it again. So
I guess I should probably go into why
that is. Um, I think the 1.0 series I
had zero visual aids and I don't think
it was in nearly enough detail and I
don't think that I knew enough to really
be talking through those questions in
depth despite doing it. Uh, in the 2.0
series, I still don't think I knew
enough. Uh, and I probably went into too
much depth and overengineered a bunch of
stuff and I think that rubbed a lot of
people the wrong way on the internet.
And now, uh, I still don't really know
enough, but I'm still getting better and
better. And I think I'm also getting
more accustomed to how people want to be
learning, looking at other resources on
the internet. And I'm going to try and
put my content in a format that is more
amendable to the learning of others. Uh,
you know, so that they can get maximum
utility out of it while also hopefully
still applying some of the knowledge
that I've gotten to pick up through some
of these deep dives over the last, you
know, 6 months to a year. uh because I
think that's really going to help kind
of augment the series a little bit and
give people the opportunity to go a
little bit further if they want to do
so. Uh as always, all of this stuff is
going to be free to to watch and you
know, it's totally my goal that I want
the videos that I post on the internet
for free to be better resources for
people than ones that people are
charging hundreds if not thousands of
dollars for. That's what's really
important to me and I care that you guys
are getting a lot out of it. Um, I will
say that uh, one thing to note is I'm
going to touch upon the video format a
little bit right now because that's
going to change a bit. I think one of
the reasons that my videos have probably
not been as strong as they could have
been in the past is because I literally
just didn't put in enough effort to
them. I would just go and I would write
out a bunch of [__] on slides or on like
some notepad and then I would just talk
through it and kind of make it up as I
went and I wouldn't edit anything. And
the problem with that is that when you
talk on the fly, uh you're sure to emit
a lot of details and you're sure to talk
in a way that uh does not make a lot of
sense to a lot of people. And I can see
that being the case from just like the
volume of questions that I get from
people and the volume of questions that
are very similar to one another on each
video where it was basically just me
going off on some sort of tangent. So,
that being said, one thing that I'm
aiming to do in this new series is I'm
going to script the entire thing. So,
it's going to sound probably a little
bit more authentic. I'm going to sound
like a bit of a tool saying the whole
thing. Uh, but at the same time, you
know, if I'm trying to provide the most
value for people, I think that speaking
clearly and concisely is the most
important thing to do. And the only way
that I really feel like I can do that
effectively is scripting. Another way
that that also helps me is it means the
slides themselves because ultimately I'm
going to use PowerPoint and Excal here.
Uh, I think the slides themselves are
going to be a lot more concise. In the
past, you may notice that my slides have
a ton of text on them and very few
images, relatively speaking. And that is
basically what every, you know,
presentation expert tells you exactly
not to do because then people are going
to get distracted by the text on the
slide. They're not going to listen to
you and a lot of the content is going to
get lost. So, I think ultimately
scripting this thing is going to be a
very effective way of presenting. But
another choice that I'm consciously
trying to make is kind of introducing
the problem a little bit earlier in the
video. So again, if you go on Reddit or
something and you see people comparing
this channel to, I don't know, like
Hello Interview or Systems Design Fight
Club or any of these other Gore apps or
whatever, uh I see a lot of people
saying that, you know, I just go off on
too many tangents or that my designs
aren't that realistic or, you know,
they've never heard of Flink. Uh [__]
you. Uh but the point is that I think
ultimately what a lot of people are
looking for, at least to start off the
video, is probably one simple design
that is good enough to get the problem
done. And it's very much true, you know,
that when you're making a design, you
shouldn't design for scale that you're
not going to have. Uh, and I've done
that in quite a few of my videos. So, I
think I'm going to try and make a
really, really conscious effort in these
videos to at least at first only make a
very simple design that is going to
achieve the scale that is realistic for
that actual website. And then from
there, what I'm going to do is, you
know, kind of finish that part up for
the video and then either make a second
part of the video or an entirely
separate video that, you know, just
comes a week later where we do a kind of
deep dive where we look at, you know,
the possible trade-offs between the kind
of simple solution that I made and what
could be done and what could maybe be
improved if all of a sudden we got, you
know, another order magnitude more of
read requests or write requests or
something like that.
I think for people who are really just
kind of looking to dip their toe into
this thing, maybe that first video would
be enough for them. But for people who
are you know higher level engineers or
feel like there's more to argue about or
just want to understand more of the
rationale behind the decisions that we
made uh I think that you know having
this kind of deep dive section and
really you know inspecting every single
design decision that I tried to make uh
will not only be a good way to foster
debate in the comments section but also
just help other people learn more if
they feel like that's something they
want to do. And then for the people who
say, you know what, I just want to look
at a video and it's going to take 15
minutes and I'm going to figure out an
answer and I'm gonna, you know, parrot
this off in my systems design interview.
Fair enough. I understand there are a
lot of people like that. And I think
that, you know, I can make both groups
happy, uh, in one series without really
giving anything up that's too much. Uh,
one more thing that I'd like to say, um,
is I don't want to milk this too much.
Uh, I think it would be very easy for me
to post basically the same video eight
times over and then label it as
Messenger and WhatsApp and then a
notification service and blah blah blah.
And at the core, they're really all the
same problem. I'm going to hope to cover
pretty much all the concepts that, you
know, people care about in these
interview questions in the minimum
number of possible videos. Uh, because,
you know, it's just a waste, I think, to
do anything else. Now, admittedly, I'm
not really incentivized to do that,
right? Because as long as you cover a
separate system and these are popular
videos, which relative to my channel
they are, then you get a lot of views
and you know that just means more
popularity for me and it, you know,
feeds my fragile ego. That being said, I
don't really think it's good for anyone
to do that. Uh, and I think it's best
that we kind of make the minimum
spanning set of these videos and then
kind of let them go where they do and
see how, you know, that's working for
people. And I'm going to, you know, try
and be open to the feedback that I'm
getting because I'm sure, especially
after the first one, there going to be a
lot of things that people do or don't
want me to do differently.
Uh, and then the final thing, uh, this
this one's probably going to be the most
controversial. So much so that I haven't
really even decided whether or not I'm
going to do it yet. And we'll probably
decide in a little bit. Um, I want to
make it so that the videos that I post
are always free. Uh, because I don't
really believe in in selling, you know,
content like that. I'm not all that
special and I just don't think people
should be paying money for it. But I
will say if you look at my channel,
you'll see that I've responded to
literally every single comment on my
channel. Uh that's not an exaggeration.
I mean certain comments of comments I
don't because it doesn't show them to me
in the YouTube like creator comments
panel. Uh but every single top level
comment that I get I try and at least
like acknowledge and respond to if I
can. um that's kind of becoming
infeasible uh with, you know, 85,000
plus subscribers at this point. Uh which
is a shame because I actually really
love interacting with you guys and I'm
going to keep trying to do it uh as much
as I can. But I also anticipate that
these videos might be getting relatively
more traction than some of my other
ones. And given that's going to be the
case, I don't know that I'll be able to
respond to every single comment uh
because I just literally have other
things going on in my life. Um, I may
open up YouTube channel memberships, uh,
for the sole reason of, you know, just
letting me prioritize certain comments
over others. Uh, I guess it would pay me
a little bit. Uh, I don't really need
the money if we're being honest. I'm not
going to pander and be like, "Oh, this
would go right back into the channel."
No, this is going to fuel my Only Fans
addiction. Um, but again, you know, just
if it comes down to, well, okay, I can
subscribe to this random comment or one
from a subscriber or one from like an
actual paying channel member and, you
know, give myself an SLA where I'm like,
okay, if you're a paying channel member,
I'm always going to respond to you
within a week. Uh, I think that's going
to, you know, make this system a lot
simple, uh, a lot more simple, you know,
for me and everyone else than it is just
being like, you know, I'm going to
comment. Maybe Jordan's going to get
back to me after like a month or
something. Uh, and that's not to say
that you can't comment, uh, and I will
never respond if you're not paying me
for it. I mean, that that would be
ludicrous. And other people can
certainly go in the comments and respond
to you. I just hope that, um, you know,
either it would thin out the comment
volumes or,
you know, get me some extra money so I
can go, you know, spend it on drugs or
something like that. So, yeah, I hope
uh, this all makes sense to people. Um,
I think the PowerPoint Excal style is
going to be really nice. Everyone hates
my handwriting. I kind of hate doing
handwriting just because I have to make
my handwriting better and then it takes
me a super long time to write. So, I'm
actually pretty amped for this myself
and I think the slides ultimately are
going to be a lot more clean and concise
for everyone to understand. Um, yeah, I
think uh we'll see how this series goes.
uh if it goes well uh then expect me to
be annoying about it and uh you know do
some self-promotion uh both you know
maybe on LinkedIn and my only fans but
uh yeah we'll see where it goes. I'm
really looking forward to it guys. I'm
going to try and put in a lot of effort
uh and not just you know kind of one
take wing this and actually make good
videos and uh we'll see if that pays off
for everyone. Have a great day and I'll
see you next week.